the final advantage of fragments doesn't
involve user interfaces at all as you
know as visual components activities are
destroyed and recreated whenever the
device configuration changes most
notably when the screen orientation
switches that makes sense because
there's a good chance we'll want to
create a different layout to better suit
the new configuration but if we can use
fragments to break out visual activity
modules why not logical ones as well it
turns out we can do exactly that and
because these fragments are non visual
there's no need to recreate them every
time the UI needs updating within the
oncreate handler of your non UI fragment
call set retain instance passing in true
and return null within your oncreateview
handler then once the parent activity is
created you can kick off any connections
threads or tasks that are bound to the
lifetime of the activity which don't
need to be interrupted every time the
device rotates